>> HAVE YOU EVER NOTICED THAT
LIBERALS HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
PATRIOTISM.
THEY WANT ATHLETES TO KNEEL
DURING THE ANTHEM.
THEY WANT TO DO AWAY WITH THE
PLEDGE AND NOW THEY HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THE FLAG.
IT HAPPENED MY ALMA MATER
TRINITY.
STUDENT HUNG A FLAG OUTSIDE HIS
DORM BLUE STRIPE FOR THE COPS,
RED STRIPE FOR THE FIREARM AND
GREEN STRIPE FOR THE FEDERAL
AGENTS.
THE DEAN DIDN'T LIKE THIS ONE
BIT AND THEY HAD SOMEONE GO TO
THE DORM AND RIP DOWN THE KIDS'
FLAGS.
APPARENTLY NO ONE DID ANYTHING
ABOUT THE PRIDE FLAGS HANGING UP
EVERYWHERE ON CAMPUS.
IN FACTS THE COLLEGE CELEBRATED
THOSE.
IT'S THE PATRIOTIC FLAGS OUTSIDE
THE DORMS THAT HAVE TO GO.
SEE, THE HANDBOOK SAYS THEY ARE
A SAFETY CONCERN.
WATCH THIS?
>> EXCUSE ME?
WHY ARE YOU GUYS TOUCHING OUR
PROPERTY?
>> YOU WERE ASKED TO TAKE IT
DOWN.
>> WHO ARE YOU TOUCHING OUR
FLAGS?
YOU HAVE NO RIGHT TO DO THIS
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
ITCH A RIDE RIGHT TO RECORD YOU
KNOW IN THIS IS AMERICA.
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT TO FREEDOM
OF SPEECH AND FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION.
>> ARE YOU TAKING DOWN OTHER
FLAGS.
>> EVERYONE IS ASKED TO TAKE
THEM DOWN.
>> THEY ARE BEING ASKED OUR FLAG
IS BEING RIPPED OFF.
>> WHAT ABOUT THAT FLAG THERE.
WHY WANT AREN'T YOU TAKING THAT
ONE FIRST [INAUDIBLE]
>> WHAT ARE YOU MEAN TO HEAR
FROM OUR DEAN.
YOU JUST TOOK OUR FLAGS DOWN.
EXCUSE ME I WILL TAKE MY FLAGS.
>> THEY GOAL TO THE DEAN'S
OFFICE.
>> DO NOT TOUCH ME.
>> I BOUGHT THESE, YOU ARE NOT
TAKING MY PROPERTY.
THIS IS STEALING.
>> Jesse: SHE KEEPS MENTIONING
THE DEAN.
WHO IS THE DEAN?
WELL, IF THEY ARE ANYTHING LIKE
THE PRESIDENT OF THE COLLEGE, IT
MAKES SENSE.
YOU SEE TRINITY PRESIDENT
SWEENEY ISN'T A FAN OF WATTERS
BUT I'M NOT GOING TO GET INTO
THAT RIGHT NOW.
GOOD GOOD NEWS IS PRESIDENT
SWEENEY NOTICED THIS LITTLE FLAG
INCIDENT GOT A LITTLE TRACTION
AND NOW SHE FEELS BAD ABOUT IT.
SENT OUT A LITTLE EMAIL TO ALL
THE STUDENTS QUOTE AS I
UNDERSTAND THE MATTER AN APOLOGY
WAS ISSUED ON THE SAME DAY THE
REMOVAL OF THE STUDENTS WHO OWN
THE FLAGS FOR THE MANNER IN
WHICH THE POLICY WAS ENFORCED.
WE WILL WORK HARDER TO ENSURE
GREATER AWARENESS AND CONSISTENT
COMPLIANCE MOVING FORWARD.
YADDA YADDA YADDA WELL WE
REACHED OUT TO THE PATRIOTS WHO
GOT THEIR FLAGS TAKEN DOWN LUCAS
AND KEN JOIN ME NOW.
SO, OTHER FLAGS ARE HANGING.
WHAT KIND OF FLAGS DO THEY HAVE
HANGING?
THEY HAD LT. FLAGS, THEY HAD
TRANSGENDER FLAGS, BLM FLAGS
WHICH WE HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH
ANY OF THOSE FLAGS HANGING WE
BELIEVE EVERYONE HAS A RIGHT TO
THEIR OWN OPINION AND BELIEFS
AND EVERYONE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
PUT THEIR FLAGS UP.
ME AND FINN THOUGHT WHY DON'T WE
PUT UP FLAGS THAT WE PERSONALLY
BELIEVE IN.
>> Jesse: HAD YOU BLACK LIVES
MATTER KIND OF THING.
THE DON'T THREAD ON ME.
>> DON'T THREAD ON ME AMERICAN
FLAG SYMBOLIZING OUR LOVE OF
FREEDOM AND QUALITY FOR ALL
PEOPLE.
RED LINE, GREEN LINE BLUE LINE
FLAG SHOWED RESPECT AND
REVERENCE FOR FIRST RESPONDERS,
OUR FAMILY MEMBERS ARE FIREMEN
AND POLICE OFFICERS.
>> Jesse: THANK YOU GUYS TO YOUR
FAMILY DID THEY EXPLAIN HOW THAT
FLAG WAS A SECURITY THREAT.
>> SECURITY, I DON'T REALLY
THINK THEY MENTIONED THAT.
THEY SAID THAT THE REASON THAT
THEY WERE TAKEN DOWN WAS BECAUSE
SOME PEOPLE VIEWED THE FLAG AS
OFFENSIVE AND I THINK THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY A SHAME THAT THOSE
FLAGS COULD BE OFFENSIVE WHEN
THEY'RE JUST ABOUT LOVING OUR
COUNTRY AND THE PEOPLE WHO
PROTECT US.
>> WHAT HAPPENED TO TRINITY?
WHEN I WAS THERE THERE WAS NO
POLITICS.
IT WAS JUST DRINKING AND SPORTS.
THE SQUASH TEAM WAS GOOD.
THE FOOTBALL TEAM WAS GOOD AND
THAT'S ALL ANYBODY CARED ABOUT
NOW THERE IS SOME SORT OF
RADICAL FLAG ACTION?
>> IT'S SAD.
FROM OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEAN THEY SEEMED VERY OPEN
APOLOGIZING.
IT DOESN'T CHANGE THE FACT WHAT
YOU SAW IN THE VIDEO THERE.
THE SAD STATE OF AFFAIRS BUT,
YOU KNOW, WE DON'T HOLD HATE IN
OUR HEART FOR THESE PEOPLE.
THE INCIDENT OCCURRED BUT WE ARE
OPEN TO HAVING PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM GOING
FORWARD.
>> Jesse: THANK YOU GUYS VERY
MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
TH